[موسيقى]
نبوءه ديبول تتحقق ميسي سيخوض مونديال
2026 كريستيانو ضمن الاسوا في كاس العالم
هذه الاخبار هو غيرها ننقولها لكم من
العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
في شهر سبتمبر الماضي اي قبل انطلاق كاس
العالم بنحو شهرين توقع رودريجيز بول لاعب
الارجنتين فوزه منتخب بلاده ببطوله كاس
العالم وكاتبه ديبول على احدى ملصقات
البوم كاس العالم انا رودريغو دي بول
اليوم هو الثامن عشر من سبتمبر الارجنتين
ستكون هي بطله العالم
اخيرا وبعد طول انتظار اصبحت صوره ميسي مع
كاس العالم هي الاكثر اعجابا على موقع
انستغرام باكثر من 59 مليون اعجاب لتتتحطى
بذلك صوره البيض الشهيره التي جمعت 56
مليون اعجاب عام 2019 كما جمعت صورته وهو
نائم مع الكاس اكثر من 15 مليون لايك بعد
ساعه فقط من نشرها
نبقى ما اخبار بطل العالم ميسي حيث اكد
نجم الارجنتين السابق
مع المنتخب
الاسباني
عام 2016 لكنه ابرز الفرق بين مارادونا
وميسي حيث لعبه يوغو موديل المكسيك وهو في
بدايته عكس ميسي الذي يقترب منها
ننتقل الى اخبار غريب ميسي كريستيانو
رونالدو الذي اختير ضمن تشكيله الاسوا
لكاس العالم بحسب موقع سوفاسكور المتخصص
في تقييم اللاعبين وكان نجم البرتغال
واحدا من اسوا 11 لاعبا غيبوا امل
الجماهيرهم وعشاقهم في المونديال المنقضي
وذلك بناء على احصائيه وارقام قدمها فريق
من المختصين للموقع